CHRIS YING: My
name is Chris Ying.
I'm the editor in chief of a
magazine called "Lucky Peach."
And our very
esteemed guest today
is Alex Atala from Brazil,
the chef of D.O.M. and Dalva e
Dito.
And my job, for
whatever reason, I've
been fortunate enough
to do a lot of traveling
the last couple of years.
And one of the preeminent
experiences of my travels
was going to Sao Paulo and
eating at D.O.M. last summer.
And it was one of these
revelatory meals where
there are flavors I
had never had before.
You get used to
eating things, and you
see different combinations
at different restaurants.
But it's really rare
that you go somewhere
and there are things
that are on your plate
that you've never experienced,
and flavors you've never
experienced, and textures and
ideas that are wholly new.
You start to think
of food as one thing.
So I think that's what you've
tried to capture in this book
today.
For those people who haven't
eaten at the restaurants,
or might not eat at the
restaurants at any time soon,
can you talk a
little bit about what
the experience of eating
at D.O.M. is, what you try
to convey?
ALEX ATALA: Brazil
cuisine abroad, it
is a huge question
for everybody.
Nobody knows Brazilian cuisine.
And for us, it's also
difficult to express.
So talking about
Brazilian cuisine
is difficult, as difficult as
talking about American cuisine.
What is American cuisine?
It's difficult.
It's not just burgers.
We have the soul.
You guys have amazing diversity.
You guys are a melting
pot of cultures.
And Brazil is almost
the same thing,
but we have something more.
We have a place which nobody
had-- or the gastronomy didn't
have [INAUDIBLE], and you
know this, which is Amazonas.
This is a new
frontier for flavor.
Unfortunately, in our
Brazilian culture, and maybe
all cultures, we always have
been looking local people,
indigenous people as
a primitive culture,
and we didn't make lots
of attention on it.
Even if they have a very
primitive or rustic cuisine
and culture, I should tell you
guys that that simplicity, that
rusticity has been
[INAUDIBLE] over generations.
There's lots of knowledge,
and lots of new ways
to understand our culture.
There's few differences.
I don't know if you know,
guys, but I was maybe
the first chef in
the fine dining world
to put one ant in a
dish, in a recipe.
Then Scott Conant
took the same idea,
and helped me to
spread this overseas.
Let me tell you my first
experience with ants.
I went to Amazonas.
And one anthropologist-- I
used to work in collaboration
with them-- told me, Alex, you
might should meet Dona Brazi.
And Dona Brazi is the local
chef in a tiny, tiny village.
And she didn't
have a restaurant.
She sells food on
the street market.
And we went in there.
And she brings me a
beautiful dark sauce
with lots of ants inside,
and said, taste it.
It's tough to eat ants,
big ants, even more.
We didn't learn this.
But my mouth is my most
accurate tool for my profession.
So I might should taste it.
I might should challenge
my mental block,
or my cultural block,
and taste that.
And I tasted it.
And I tasted the sauce,
and beautiful aroma
of lemongrass and ginger.
I became so impressed, and I
said, Dona Brazi, what kind
of herb did you put in there?
And I ask because we didn't
have lemongrass and ginger
in Amazonas culture.
And she said ants.
And I said, OK, I
can see the ants.
It's clear.
But which herb?
And she said ants.
And I tried to
remake the question.
And she said, stop.
Taste the ants.
And I grabbed one ant and I put
in my mouth, and this huge wave
of aroma and flavor, full of
ginger and lemongrass-- wow.
And I said, wow,
I might use this.
So I decided to take a
few ants to my restaurant
and start using there.
And also in my next
trip, I had planned
to bring with me some
ginger and lemongrass.
And I did it.
And I made almost
the same sauce,
and I invited Dona
Brazi to taste it.
And she was expecting
something new
from a chef who comes from
Sao Paulo, from the big city.
And I gave to her,
and she tasted it.
It tasted like ants.
First thing, first very
important thing-- for us,
ants taste as
lemongrass and ginger.
From them, lemongrass
and ginger taste
as an ant-- different points
of view, different cultures.
And then I went back to my
restaurant with my ants,
almost ashamed to use
ants in my restaurant.
So I didn't have self confidence
enough to put one entire ant,
and make my customer,
which is paying nice money,
to taste the ants.
So I must figure out one way.
So I made powder-- ants
powder, beautiful, black--
and I put it over
a scampi risotto.
And nobody couldn't believe
that this big, nice flavor
comes from the ants.
So they were looking
for the ants.
And they said, it's
beautiful, but I
can't find the
taste of the ants.
I said, no, no it's
the lemongrass.
They said, no, no, no, the ants.
I decided to make a small
pineapple, almost frozen, very,
very cold, with one ant,
and give to the customer,
and prove this challenge.
It's just one ant.
It's just one.
People can face this.
And it's fun when you
see the expressions.
It's fun, because
everybody looks
and doesn't feel comfortable.
It is a big ant.
And then people must take
with their hands and bite.
And of course, the first flavor
that comes is the pineapple.
And people start to bite,
and they can't believe.
And the reactions
are so profound.
And we are talking
now about flavor.
We are talking about
emotions, how much
surprise or good feelings
one food can bring for us.
| or palette, is something that
we develop during the years.
Kids do not like alcohol,
or bitter taste, or spicy.
We learned how to
appreciate those flavors.
When I was a tiny, tiny
boy, my grandmother
used to make a beautiful
corn cake for me.
And that corn cake for
me was the best flavor,
or my first connection
with a good flavor.
And I really became-- wow.
I grew up, and we
moved to another city.
So I lost a little
bit the connection,
my daily connection with
my family, or my grandma.
And I grew up with always that
amazing flavor in my memory.
And a few years later, I could
have the possibility of taste
again the same
beautiful corn cake
that my grandma used to make.
And I tasted it, and
it wasn't so good.
My flavor was developed.
I was not a tiny boy.
But until today, when I taste
something really surprising,
I still think, this
is as good as the corn
cake of my grandmother.
We are not talking about
flavor, but how much emotions
a new flavor can bring for you.
So I try to figure out
this, both in my recipes,
just because I didn't
work with common flavors.
I work with new flavors.
And the best way to
challenge, I guess,
should taste those
new flavor might
be in a very comfortable way.
We are chefs.
Our first commitment,
it's give pleasure
to people who come
to our restaurant.
People don't go to
restaurants for suffering.
People go to restaurants
for enjoying.
But we can try to give
a few more sensations.
So this is mainly
the way that we work.
CHRIS YING: I think that's
a really perfect description
of what it is to eat at
D.O.M. You're challenged,
but I've been to so many meals
that are like suffering, where
trying to teach you
something, and you
feel like they're slapping
you on the wrist when
you don't understand right away.
But D.O.M. is
pleasurable, and you're
educating people and educating
yourself at the same time.
But that's not
necessarily the reason
why Alex is one of
"Time" magazine's
most 100 influential
people, whatnot,
why he's built up this
reputation around the world.
D.O.M. And you personally
have a bigger mission
than just putting
food on the plate.
You have things are
more important to you
than just serving dinner.
Do you want to talk about
some of those things?
ALEX ATALA: Well,
let's take this subject
in two different ways.
One is my message
from Brazilian people.
Those ingredients
that I use and you
can find in my book, lots and
lots and lots of Brazilians
never ever tasted before.
Even Brazilians don't know.
So my first compromise is
show to Brazilian people
that Brazilian cuisine
is a possible dream.
And we have lots much
more than feijoada,
or barbecue, or picanha.
I love it, but as you guys
in America have burgers,
and it's beautiful, but
it's not whole America.
We have feijoada.
We have rodizio or picanha.
But this is not all
Brazilian cuisine.
And people [INAUDIBLE]
me this attention.
As a colonized country,
even me, we always
have more eyes for
other cultures.
We never look at our
culture with pride.
I don't know why
Brazilian always
have been looking at our local
culture as something poor.
And sometimes I became
mad with Brazilians
because we have fine dining,
and we have street food.
Street food in Brazil has
been almost forbidden.
And we are fighting
to rescue this.
And also something that
we call boteco-- boteco
is finger food that
we have just to drink.
And it's amazing.
But people who went to
boteco used to say this
is not high gastronomy.
It's low gastronomy.
And I became-- you got it.
[LAUGHS] i became mad with this.
Why?
Because it's cheap, it's low?
What do you fucking
mean, high gastronomy?
High gastronomy is not to
work with fancy ingredients.
It is to put one
ingredient or one recipe
in their best moment.
And this is easy to understand.
Let's make a supposition here.
You Americans love
burgers and hot dogs.
And everybody knows where is
the best hot dog or the best
burger.
And those places
are very busy, ever.
A sushi man in Japan
is an honorable man.
His honorability is the
customer who goes to them.
He makes sushi for
people who have
been eating sushi
their entire lives.
And they know this is the guy.
Creativity is not
to do something
that nobody did before.
It's to do something that
everybody does, better,
surprisingly.
This is the way.
People really want to
square high gastronomy
in truffles, foie gras,
small dishes, lots of money.
Come on.
This is a fucking old idea.
That's true.
I'm not kidding.
I have much more pleasure
sometimes those mornings
I went to the pier,
and I ate a sandwich
with ramp and fried eggs.
And that was good.
That was really good.
That brings me surprise.
I ate one egg in
an unexpected way.
There is something new
happens in the world.
You guys from Google know this.
Until when we are going
to think that cuisine
is only for rich people?
Cuisine is human,
as human as sex is.
It's pleasure.
It's to share.
Come on.
Food is much more.
Food is culture.
We should rethink about
our relation with food.
Talking about now about
review our concept.
One month ago, a little bit
more, Chris was with me.
We went to MAD food
camp in Copenhagen.
Rene Redzepi, our friend, runs
one of the best and interesting
some food congresses
in the world.
I will try to explain this.
All of the food congresses,
you have a very friendly chef
with his beautiful
knife, his nice pants,
animating fucking recipes.
This is a circus.
Sorry.
You can see this on television.
You don't need to
go to a congress.
It's usually the same.
It didn't taste as well.
Television doesn't taste.
Congress didn't taste.
That's the reason why
you go to restaurants.
MAD food camp, it
is a huge panel
of the big picture of cuisine,
of food, not only the food
chain, but the food web.
Food this is a cross line
between nature and culture.
Food is the main track of
research of all human science.
And Rene put all those
beautiful ideas together.
So he invited me-- I don't
know why-- to MAD food camp,
and I wear this shirt with
this beautiful message.
And I showed very strong videos.
Rene has read one text which
I have in my book about death.
And I enter on the stage,
and I kill a chicken.
I didn't say nothing.
And everybody became so choked.
Instead of killing a chicken,
if I had killed a fish,
maybe the message
would be not so deep.
If you go to a
fishmonger, you can
see lobster, crabs,
beautiful fish.
This is beautiful for our eyes.
But if you go to a butcher shop
and you see calves, chicken,
lambs, pigs, that is not good.
It's not comfortable.
Why?
For myself, the
only reason is fish
didn't change their expression.
He keeps living.
Yeah.
The fish didn't
have expressions.
They didn't die for our eye,
our cultural interpretation
of death.
I'm a huge fan of
vegetarianism, a huge fan.
Even in my cookbook, I made
texts about vegetarianism.
In my restaurant, last
five years or even more,
I have a vegetarian taste menu.
But sometimes, people
said, I'm vegetarian
because I have compassion of
my da da da da, poor animals.
Fuck you.
Death happens.
I might should tell you
guys, go to Amazonas,
and you'll see how much land has
been deforested to feed people.
Deforestation
didn't kill animals.
It sterilized one
entire ecosystem.
So if you are this
type of vegetarian,
please come to visit Amazonas.
Come to see what it
means green deserts.
There's no lives inside of
that-- green fields sterile.
Brazil nowadays is
the worst, the leader
of chemical emission
in agriculture.
The chemicals go from somewhere.
Our relation with food
might be reviewed.
This is a bad way to
talk about a review.
But there's other possibilities.
My relation with
those ingredients,
with Brazilian ingredients, it
started in the very beginning,
or maybe a few years before,
[? O Pendon, ?] which
has 14 years already.
I decided to use
Brazilian ingredients,
but those Brazilian ingredients
weren't on the market.
So I started to call
friends and local people,
and trying to connect
everybody to have
that beautiful ingredient
in my restaurant.
In the Brazilian
market, I could only
find industrial level
of medium quality
of Brazilian ingredients.
After 14, 15 years, this
relation became too big, too,
too big.
So I decided to
make a foundation
because that relation didn't
fit anymore into a restaurant.
And I realized that
as a chef, I was not
able to handle that situation.
And I will try to tell
to you guys the day
that I realized that I was
not able to play that game.
12 years ago-- well, let's
go a little bit back,
when I had been trained
to be a chef in Europe.
And lots of good
chefs in Europe used
to plant their own
vegetables, their own herbs.
And this is so nice.
I agree with that.
I love that idea.
So as a trained
chef, I learned you
think you can raise
your own ingredients.
And you can also understand
that the most important moment
for a chef is not the
service when the guest comes.
It is the prep, what
we call mise en place.
If you didn't have a very
well done and organized mise
en place, you're going to
lose in between the service,
lose yourself.
12 years ago, I bought
a huge area in Amazonas.
The ex-owner in a small
community, local community,
used to fight because part
of the area, both of them
believed they owned it.
When I bought the area,
I bought the problem.
So I decided to
solve the problem.
And I went in there.
I had a one entire afternoon
conversation with the natives.
And in the end, I made a
very simple proposition.
I said to them, which
part of the area
you believe it is yours?
They said, there, there, there.
I said, OK, go to the
city, pay the tax,
and I will never, ever--
and nobody will never, ever
touch your lands.
And they made it.
And I became so proud.
I started to feel myself the
smartest, coolest, intelligent,
near to God, really
near, almost beside him.
And I couldn't play with this.
That area in Amazonas
is a very poor area,
but is not a miserable area.
That community, they used
to have lots of kids.
It was clear that even
if they have food,
maybe kids were underfed.
So I decided to
send food to them.
And I started to send.
A few months later,
I went to this area.
To enter in my
area, I might should
cross the local
community in the area.
And when I passed
by there, there
were cans and plastic
bags everywhere.
Duh, you smart guy.
Stop the car.
I started to explain to them
that they couldn't do this.
It's awful.
You live in Amazonas.
A can, a plastic
bag, that's not good.
And they didn't understand.
They became upset with me.
So the temperature
started to rise up,
and I became not comfortable.
And one of the oldest men
faced me and said, Alex,
it's your fault.
I said, sir, sorry.
I started to send food for
your grandchildren, which
have almost the same age
that your youngest son,
and you try to blame me.
And he answered
almost like this.
Packaging of fruits is the skin.
Packaging of fish is the scales.
Packaging of one animal is fur.
I throw away.
At the first moment, the
skin looks very violent.
But who was sending the cans
and the plastic bags to them?
That was the day that I
realized that maybe as a chef,
I can handle the food
chain, but not the food web.
That was the day that
I realized that this
is an interdisciplinary
thing, and I
might should learn and be
supported by anthropologists,
by sociologists, by
different disciplines.
One year ago, a little bit more,
I made public the institute
which the only goal
that we can try to do
is try to organize
this food chain,
and try to do not cross the
line for the food web, which
is a human web.
A few days ago, a
journalist has asked me,
why use ants if they have a
lemongrass and ginger taste?
Why not?
Until when we are going
to still believe that
our culture is superior
than the other?
Until when we are
going to believe that
we know more than the others?
In Portuguese, we have a very
nice expression which says,
if to speak was
better than listening,
we would be born with
two mouths and a one ear.
We might should understand them.
It is primitive, it is
simple, it is rustic.
Yes, it is.
Maybe it's not so complex.
Yes, it isn't.
But it's deep.
They have been living in
Amazonas for generations.
They didn't make
big damages in there
as we made in the last 50 years.
50 years is just because it
is the years which agriculture
has really entered in
Amazonas area, even less.
But again, we can
learn with them.
We might respect them.
We can try to defend the nature.
Everybody knows when we talk
about natural conservation
that we might should protect
rivers, sea, lands, forests.
But we can forget
a natural being
which is the human
being who lives
inside or near the forest,
the lands, the sea.
We honor the nature.
We are just part of the nature.
CHRIS YING: No, I think that one
of the most interesting things
you've said and you
cover in this book
is that idea that cuisine is
the connection between nature
and culture, and that's
something that sort
of transcends just
eating at the restaurant.
And what you're trying
to do in Amazonas
is using cuisine as
this tool for change.
And it's a really powerful tool
that I think a lot of chefs
haven't quite realized
how powerful it
is to achieve positive things.
I'm going to ask you
one more question,
and then if anybody else has
any questions, you can chime in.
So the book is very specific
to these ingredients that
are Brazilian, and you have to
be there with these ingredients
to understand them and get
the full effect of the book.
So what do you want to try to
achieve this book for readers
in America, readers in
Europe who aren't in Brazil?
What can they take from it?
What is the message
underlying the Brazilian part?
ALEX ATALA: Well,
first of all, I
tried to show
people that we have
much more to show in the
sense of ingredients.
If Spain, Italy, France, Japan,
are referenced as gastronomy,
it's not because they have only
ingredients and one good chef.
They have lots of ingredients
and lots of good chefs.
We have nowadays
amazing, really amazing
new generation of
chefs coming up,
and they might be supported.
And they might
believe in their own.
And they might have eyes
for their own culture.
So this is one of the messages
of the cookbook, again, trying
to make people believe
that Brazilian cuisine is
a possible dream.
Try to people rethink about
or review their own relation
with food, even if it's
tough, it's disgusting,
see someone killing a chicken.
Our grandma used to do, and
we have a so romantic memory
from that flavor.
And our grandma used to
save even the feathers.
Urban chefs nowadays just
take the phone-- urban chefs.
I'm not talking all
chefs in the world.
But in general, chefs
just order ingredients,
or part of ingredients--
rack of lamb,
fillet of salmon, chicken wings.
How much you waste?
What is our relation with
the trash, the garbage?
People super cool.
They select the trash, and
then they put out of house,
and close the door-- finished.
No.
This goes somewhere.
We might to understand this,
to use better our ingredients,
and respect more that
live chicken who I killed,
or we kill every day.
Sorry, guys.
All chickens that you have
ate in your life has died.
It is amazing.
It's funny how we lost this.
And even chefs-- I can
even go one step forward.
Chefs, lots of chefs
nowadays, have more fear
for one entire dead
animal in his kitchen
than one alive animal
in his kitchen.
One alive animal,
you can push away.
But one entire dead animal, no.
Why do you make sausage?
Our previous generations used
to make sausage for saving meat,
to preserve dead life,
dead meat longer.
Human relations with
food might be reviewed.
It is as simple as it.
Behind every dish,
there's death,
even if you are
vegetarian or vegan.
Sorry, guys.
Behind ever dish,
there is death.
CHRIS YING: You've been talking
about the institute you started
to try to connect the
supply line from Amazonas
to the restaurants, and connect
these people who are growing
ingredients to the urban market.
Can you talk a little bit
about what you guys do,
what the institute does?
ALEX ATALA: Today I was
visiting your amazing campus,
and someone told me that
you guys produce honey.
And I became fascinated by it.
Let me tell you what
we do with honey,
and what is these bees
that you guys have.
Those bees who
produce honey that we
have been eating for our entire
life, it is one type of bee
called apis mellifera.
If you don't know, Google it.
It's easy.
We didn't have this
bee in America.
This bee has been introduced
from Africa and Europe
into Americas.
This bee produces a
huge amount of honey.
And the honey is very stable.
The honey that we
know has 20% humidity.
That means you can leave in
your cuisine, in your kitchen,
in your room, and it will be
the same product ever-- maybe
crystallized, but
there is no change.
Between north of
Argentina and to Florida,
we have more than 500
different types of honeybees.
They are tiny, tiny, tiny bees.
They didn't produce
lots of honey.
But the flavor of those
honeys are amazing.
These tiny bees didn't have
stings, so they didn't bite us.
They're called friendly bees.
This honey has
medical possibilities,
but for some reason,
which is healthy,
security, or health loss
[SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
parameters, those
honeys in Brazil,
we are not allowed to use.
We can't use it.
I can't use it.
I use it.
And I pray every day
for someone to arrest me
because I'm using an illegal
ingredient in my restaurant.
Let me try to explain this.
That honey is not
legal just because they
have between 30%
and 35% humidity.
It is a live ingredient,
as live as wine or cheese.
Fermentation happens in there.
Now, this is super trendy in
our [INAUDIBLE] cuisine talking
about fermentation.
I used to do as well.
But fermentation
happens everywhere,
and we might [INAUDIBLE].
So this is a live ingredient
that we can manage.
There's no real risks for human
population in those honeys.
But unfortunately, our law
has simply forgot this.
In one single
ingredient, we can see
all the food chain connected.
If I change, or our institute
achieves to change this law,
and this product became
legal, as a chef,
I can have a few more
flavors, a few more,
because it's not
one flavor of honey.
It's a huge variation of flavor.
My customers, the
foodies, are going
to have a few more ingredients.
Medical research can also
have more possibilities.
Local people can
raise these bees.
They are friendly,
so they didn't
bite kids or dogs or pets.
You can have it at home.
They are tiny bees.
It's part of our biodiversity.
It's part of our culture.
If that can be income
for local people,
there is a social benefit.
There's economic benefit.
And the last step--
bees just produce
honey in a healthy ecosystem.
So in one single ingredient,
you can understand all the food
chain.
We are trying to
make these products.
So nowadays, we are
working with honey.
We are pushing one project,
which is Amazonas mushrooms.
It is funny that
our culture don't
know about possible
mushrooms in Amazonas.
So in Brazil, if you
want to buy mushrooms,
you must buy [INAUDIBLE]
champignon, portobello,
shimeji, shiitake, but
we didn't have our own.
And natives used to
harvest, and we didn't know,
or we knew but we
didn't make it.
So we are trying to create
a project or a meeting,
but not trying to make
mushroom farms in Amazonas.
We just find the spots
and put more wood.
These mushrooms grow in dead
pieces, or old pieces of wood.
So we are putting
them in, and we
hope that after December,
in one month and a half,
the rainy season
starts again, and we
will see if this idea
is going to work.
But I do believe that
that can be possible.
I lost myself.
Sorry.
We have nowadays nine
different projects,
always connect one ingredient
with the local producers.
One of the most
beautiful is the rice.
Nine years ago, a little bit
back, agrobusiness in Brazil
is very important
for our economy.
Rice production is always so
important for our economy.
There's a long valley between
Sao Paulo called Rio de Janeiro
Janeiro called the
Vale do Paraiba.
It's the first rice plantation,
or the first rice plant
tradition that we
have in Brazil.
Almost 50 years ago, south of
Brazil starts producing rice,
and south of Brazil, the
ground, the soil is much better.
So they produced double
amount by hectare, the valley.
In a country which agrobusiness
is a scale business,
that valley was
already increased.
They didn't produce as much,
The small producers even more,
because rice was a commodity,
and they didn't have scale.
So they have been pushed
from their own land.
One researcher,
or one scientist,
which we call breeder,
decided to convince
one small producer
to plant black rice.
Just to let you know, guys,
in Brazil, in the old days,
black rice was considered a
disease, a rice disease, OK?
This breeder has
convinced this young guy
to produce this black rice.
And they made it.
And they have a huge success.
They harvested a
huge amount of rice.
The problem was, nobody
wants to buy black rice.
For our culture, black
rice is not a good rice.
They became a complete loss.
So they decided-- this
is a true history--
they decided to buy gastronomic
magazines, and they found me.
So one day I was in my
restaurant nine years ago.
They touched at my door.
I opened the door.
It was a small producer, very
dressed as a countryside guy,
and this researcher.
They gave me this black rice.
Please, help us, they said.
I tasted it, and the texture
and flavor was beautiful.
So I started to use
in the same day.
And I started to talk with
other chefs, and thank God,
the Brazilian press has also
talked largely about this rice.
Nowadays, this rice
has spread everywhere,
really everywhere,
even in Amazonas.
Between three and four years
ago, this breeder got cancer.
And he knew that
he was terminal.
So he called me and said,
Alex, come to is visit me.
I want to talk with you.
I went in there, and he showed
me a tiny, tiny, tiny bowl
of rice, ball-shaped rice,
and said please, do something
with this.
I'm going to pass away, and
this is my last research.
We made it.
Nowadays, this rice is,
again, spread in everywhere.
But the beautiful, the
most beautiful history,
or beautiful goal
of this history
is not the black rice
or the small rice.
All the valley nowadays
is not planting
black rice or mini rice.
All the small producers
are planting special rice.
I mean koshihikari,
Japanese rice, jasmine rise,
basmati rice.
They realized
something very simple.
Big wines, big cheeses
in Europe are not
produced by big companies.
Producing quality can
be the biggest goal
for a small producer,
if the market pays.
Our dream in Ata is keep
doing things like this.
This project with
the rice, for me,
it's very meaningful,
because the biggest goal
it is to change
one local culture.
We are learning something more
which is very tough for us.
We created a label, which
is called Retratas do Gosto.
That means faces of flavor,
maybe something like this.
And we give all support
for local people
if they produce a good
ingredient, healthy ingredient.
And we to package and
to sell everything.
And we have benefits,
economic benefits.
25% of our benefits, might
go back to the lands,
not for the producer.
So you with the black
rice, what we did
was build a new
research center, not
to help only the
guys who were already
planting black rice or
small rice or mini rice,
guys who are not included
in our philosophy
to plant different
rice or special rice.
The next step, try to convince
them to plant organic rice.
And let me explain why.
These small producers
sometimes need money.
They might go to the bank.
The bank might
guarantee his money.
And the only way that
the bank can believe,
and also the small producer
believe that the harvest will
be safe, and they can pay back
the bank, is buying chemicals.
So when a Brazilian small
producer signs a bank contract,
it's included that he might
buy those specific seeds that
come from a big company,
and those chemicals that
come from another company.
This is a cultural barrier.
Those guys, I can't
blame them, the bank
or the small producers.
It is just a cultural barrier.
They didn't believe that
organic food is a possible way.
They don't know.
How can one bank be convinced
that organic agriculture
is something real, if
there are companies
who support money
to sell chemicals?
And nobody can
explain to them how
we can change the culture
from the local people,
if the last 15 years, they
only learned to put chemicals,
and nobody knows
anymore how to--
So it is our
commitment nowadays,
is to try to improve
the food chain,
organize, revalue,
and trying to not make
big changes in the food web.
It is two very difficult
lines, but we keep trying.
And I don't know if
we will be successful,
but it's our challenge.
AUDIENCE: You were talking
before about the size
of the United States, and
that it's a melting pot,
and that there's so many
different flavors here.
And I think about the
size of the Amazon,
and it's humongous
on the scale that's
difficult to comprehend,
which would tend
to make me think that throughout
there, even the native cultures
are going to have
a lot of variations
and different flavors
and different styles.
And how has that
affected your cooking?
ALEX ATALA: Well,
this on one hand
gives us more possibilities.
So it's on one hand
super exciting.
Of course, when you
have this big melting
pot, which we are as
well, it is not so easy.
But why do you stop your
car when the sign is red?
It is not to not crash your car.
Is for benefits for the
whole entire community,
to help traffic.
I mean, this is the
most simple thing.
We might to believe
that it's possible.
If you start to do, someone
is going to start to do,
and this creates a kind of wave.
Chefs nowadays have
more voice than ever.
Our first commitment, of
course, is make nice food
for customers.
But we can go one step forward.
We can try to provoke
a few changes.
If I have a voice, I can
have more voice to say,
look how beautiful I am.
Or I can have more voice
to spread another message.
And we are trying to do this.
I don't know if it's too
romantic, almost utopic.
But man, when I
went in the kitchen,
nobody wants you to be a chef.
I was a punk rocker.
Nobody wanted to give
a job for myself.
So I can keep going.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: With the world cup
and the Olympics coming up,
what are you doing
in preparation
to help spread that message,
as in international guests
will be arriving in Brazil?
ALEX ATALA: This is a
challenging, difficult,
and good question.
As a chef, my first thought
is I can't answer this.
This is a government thing.
I can solve a few
problems that I have.
As a Brazilian
citizen, all the world
will be watching my country.
We might do something.
It is time to show how beautiful
things are happening in Brazil.
As a chef, and part
of one institute,
we are trying to
share our know-how.
So we have a small project with
kids with a few things, one
of them, and maybe I
will not talk today.
But I really
believe that cuisine
can be a very possible way
to social reintegration.
My sous chef, my
right arm in cuisine
was a guy who, 14 years ago,
wasn't able to write or read.
14 years later, he's trying
to enter in a university.
There's different
levels of reintegration,
or social reintegration.
And all of them, the
kitchen can be helpful.
So we are trying
to do a few things.
We are planting seeds.
I don't know how big are going
to be this herb or this tree.
But we keep doing.
CHRIS YING: Thanks.
Thanks, Alex.
ALEX ATALA: Thank you, guys.
Thank you, Google.
[APPLAUSE]